[Music]
it's hard to think of any athlete better
known or more polarizing than alex
rodriguez he's done it again
[Music]
[Applause]
he joins the 3 000 hit club a three-time
mvp 14-time all-star and world series
champion he retired in 2016 as the
highest paid player in mlb history
fourth all-time on the list of home runs
but his playing career isn't likely to
be remembered by those statistics or by
who he is or isn't dating a record
suspension tonight for baseball star
alex rodriguez over his use of
performance-enhancing drugs you say you
did not do these peds that they are
accusing you of doing you're correct
mike okay this dude is unbelievable a
phony to the end
while it was the most painful time of my
life
it may cost me the hall of fame and
that's on me nobody else
i think in a weird way i'm going to look
back and say that's one of the also one
of the best things that happened
five years after his retirement alex
rodriguez the ceo is getting back into
sports this time as an owner of a pro
basketball team and he wants to build
more than just a franchise but a legacy
maybe with a dose of redemption
the mistakes made in baseball
are done and i can't go back and fix
them
i want to keep
a clean record as a father as a friend
as a business person
and because those mistakes i think i
have that opportunity
and i'm having a time of my life doing
it
[Music]
a-rod alex rodriguez is buying the
minnesota timberwolves and the minnesota
lynx the purchase price is expected to
be in the range of 1.5 billion dollars
you know for me
i think
making the transition from player to
owner something that's very exciting to
me i'm really excited to bring my
experience both in business
and in sports and in a locker room and
do really really exciting things and
bring a world championship to the city
in april 2021 alex rodriguez joined one
of the most exclusive clubs around
folks who own a pro sports team and
while his name and his fame made the
headlines it was his business empire
that allowed him to actually close the
deal the easy to remember name a rod
corp it's grown into a diversified
investor and operator taking a cue from
mega firms like blackstone and kkr a
ride corp has taken a real estate
portfolio and expanded into venture
capital and private equity and media
and like any business in 2021 its own
spec
i was more lucky than smart i started
investing very small in real estate
simply as a hedge to
as my earning power would close
my real estate would not only appreciate
what's but create more cash flow and
then i would take their cash flow and i
would buy more real estate and other
private equity type investments were
generated more cash flow so as my yankee
income went to zero
hopefully my real estate and my
businesses will grow over time
and while players nowadays are becoming
better and better business brands few
are able to achieve the scale as a-rod
corp has in such a relatively short
amount of time but understanding how
that growth happened in business just
like baseball has to start at home
[Music]
part of what i love about business is
you get to build things from nothing
right like nothing so
i had two hip surgeries and i never
wanted to be the old guy that couldn't
get up you know the stairs so i built a
flat house
all entertainment on that side
my room here dad and the girls on this
side but it had to be one story because
hey i'm always forgetting things
and b
i i didn't want to be like oh my god
i can't get up the steps because of
these sips
yeah i walk around here i mean first of
all the art's beautiful but
tons of pictures of of of you and the
girls and
i mean you've really made
a family life for yourself here tell me
about that well i'll tell you what i'm
not at home
i'm not a cleanup hitter and i'm not a
ceo
the girls remind me every day that i
work for them
people always ask me what do you do in
your life and i say the three b's i do
baseball now basketball too
business and my babies and that's kind
of
that's my happy zone
it's funny through pandemic
we spend so much time here and in my 46
years
the toughest time in the world that i've
witnessed on the other side of that we
were in here and we felt safe and we
felt loved
and it was like 90 days of breakfast
lunch and dinner with my girls it was a
dream come true they got so sick of my
dad jokes
so sick of my dancing
natasha would at least do tick-tock i've
been begging trying to bribe ella to do
one with me she was daddy you have no
swag no drip i'm not doing anything with
you a-rod's dancing may not get his
daughter's approval but his following on
social media is huge with nearly 4
million followers on instagram alone
that number is larger than his new
basketball team the yankees or the red
sox not to mention any other single
baseball player current or former who
has better taste in music
whose room is decorated nicer
what is it that
makes you engage the way you do in
social you know jason a lot of that came
through my time
during my suspension you know i spent a
whole year
serving a suspension and in that time
i had an opportunity to turn
the lens inward
and
understand why i was making some of the
good choices the poor choices the bad
choices
and understand kind of conversation
understand storytelling and it's
something that i'm enjoying is still
fairly new we're not experts by any
means but every time
we look at companies or opportunities or
partnerships is data driven and social
driven and
it's been a quite a tool for us
that suspension which obviously people
will forever associate you with
and there's an interesting choice you
make there
at that moment and then in subsequent
moments
to
[Music]
not lean out to not retreat but to lean
in to some extent and especially in in
the last couple years
tell me about that
if you think about my career sure i've
hit home runs and
been part of a world championship team
but i'm also
i'm fifth all time in the history of
strikeouts
i mean that means that only four people
in the history of mankind have
failed more than me
um
but i think as a result i've been you
know phd in failing but also an mba of
getting back up looking around at his
house and his selection of cars
it's hard to say that a-rod has ever
really failed
but it's striking what he has built
considering where he came from
[Music]
i was born in new york
raised in miami so when i got to miami
it was around eight and a half nine
years old my father left
uh when i was around ten
and at home it was mom my brother joe
and my sister susie they took the role
of like
my brother became like the secretary of
sports my sister became the secretary of
education
and my mom just had to you know make
enough money to pay our bills
i think you know my father leaving us at
10
kind of left a huge
vacant spot right and i think i
i needed to then
kind of fill that void
by having a collection of mentors
one of those earliest mentors was his
baseball coach rich hoffman right here
at westminster high school
steve walked through this this area a
few times oh yeah
this brings back some pretty cool
memories
if you hit a home run here goes to the
basketball courts in the pool right and
i kind of like it it's kind of like got
this
fenway kind of wrigley
instead of the green monster you have
the the green palms yes exactly
well it's really where i really
started to understand the power of
mentorship and dreaming big
and if you think about it i have one of
the most important conversations with
coach rich hoffman and that happened at
15 the first day i walked on campus
he goes look alex you're gonna come in
this year you're gonna have a good year
and then you're going to
the junior olympics uh to represent the
u.s
you'll do well there you'll get much
stronger
by that time you'll be like the top
junior in the country
and then your senior year you're going
to be the number one pick in the country
and then you're going to be off to the
big leagues
coach you're talking to me
he goes yeah i'm talking to you alex
and jason i went home that night
and i believed him it just like it
changed my complete vision
on
me
and my future
and then i did everything in my power
not to let coach down
so as a leader today when i have young
people
it's my job to not only give them the
opportunity but to push them
and push them to a level where they now
see the world in a different way about
themselves that prediction came true
in the 1993 mlb draft rodriguez was
selected first overall by the seattle
mariners and while his playing career
was just getting started by the age of
22 he'd invest in his first piece of
real estate
it was what i knew best my mother
uh she wasn't a homeowner she was we
were renters right we were tenants
and every 18 months we would move
because the landlord would always raise
the rents
and i remember as a young kid saying boy
if i can ever trade places
with the landlord and
they can be the tenant that would be
amazing
i bought my first duplex
and then i owned that for a few years i
sold it for double
about four plex eight plex
60 units
and and off we went when it came to
those first investments um you know
whenever he does something he's going in
at 100 percent this is jose gomez
everyone calls him pepe along with jose
mouri he's the co-ceo of newport
property construction and also a
childhood friend of rodriguez from 2004
to 2007 we ended up acquiring 5100 units
between florida and texas we renovated
him he would buy them i would renovate
them and uh and you know the rest was
history being a real estate investor
especially in high growth markets like
florida well it hasn't been a straight
line up for the past two decades miami's
high-rise condos are monuments to a
burst property bubble almost half of
florida mortgages are underwater we had
this run up to 2007 prices were going up
like this
and then it just fell off a cliff the
great recession crushed owners and
developers alike
few were immune
except those that had other sources of
income to take advantage of falling
prices
income like say
one of the richest baseball contracts in
history
our huge advantage was that alex had w2
income coming in from playing and we had
that stay in power so we were able even
when when things started going you know
south for some people we were able to
grow within those difficult times
monument capital management has done
more than 60 deals since 2012 worth more
than 900 million dollars
the extent of that ambition in real
estate is evident here at grand station
in downtown miami
the 30-story residential tower complete
with a sprawling amenity floor and pool
has sweeping views of downtown
it's a bet on miami's growth and it's a
bet that's looking smarter as wall
street firms and other companies look
southward
people always question miami why do
people live there there's not any great
jobs you know we don't have a lot of
financial services here we don't have
anybody manufacturing anything
but that's changing
people see this as a very cool place to
live and work now before it was all it
was always a cool place to live but
where are you going to work now it's
okay the jobs are here first cool place
to visit in the past right yeah and now
each pocket is being built out i think
art basel years and years ago started
that and then there have been a course
of events that have followed that
continue to enrich miami and i would say
we're still early as a city
but while miami may be home base
rodriguez's most aggressive current real
estate project is buying renovating and
renting out single-family homes in
markets across the country
and in this case he's not just emulating
some of the world's biggest investors
but also getting into business with them
including real estate legend barry
sternlich
just as behemoths like blackstone have
amassed single-family homes rodriguez
through the tiber capital group has
snapped up 5 000 homes so far
we think we're still in the early
innings of single-family housing rents
are going up about 18 to 19 percent once
we find something
then you know this i learned from from
warren buffett is you know be
disciplined but when you find your pitch
you know don't go for a single or a
double you know go in and go on big and
that's exactly what we've done
multi-family and now with single-family
houses
going big has required rodriguez to
build a team around him and he's opted
for a delicate balance of homegrown and
outside hires
on the one side friends dating back to
childhood and adolescence including
aaron pepe and jose on the other newer
editions such as kelly laferriere stuart
zuck david becker and lisa pyre
managing the chemistry among the small
and growing team is akin to the elusive
intangibles rodriguez saw in clubhouses
when he was a player
getting it right
well that's the difference between being
a champion and an also ran uh lisa take
it away sure so i think next we're going
to have dave on tigger wolves
uh
one exciting development is the 12-17
campaigns the lakers is going to espn so
we were not on the eastman schedule now
we are
at the art corp offices you'll notice
the memorabilia the pictures of famous
athletes the real-time social data being
displayed on the tv wall
but you'll also see pictures of
rodriguez with some of the biggest
businessmen in the world alex has become
a sponge
and he started that as an active player
when he was on the road he would go and
visit the jury reinstalls of the world
in his uniform and ask them business
questions and he surrounded himself with
really good smart people the wide
network is critical in sourcing deals
including in venture world where the
a-rod portfolio has included more than
60 companies brands like hims and hers
go puff and ufc gyms but having the best
team doesn't mean you win every at bat
their spack slam corp was recently
negotiating a roughly 3 billion deal to
merge with collectible company panini
that didn't materialize after panini
stumbled
slam's still in search of a target
but rodriguez's belief in taking swings
striking out and hitting big is also the
same way he would end up with his own
sports franchise
[Music]
jlo and a-rod are angling to buy the new
york mets they're not just angling i
mean they are in the process of putting
the money together rodriguez along with
a group that included his then
girlfriend jennifer lopez entrepreneur
mark lori and several others mounted a
bid against front runner and hedge fund
billionaire stephen a cohen these guys
are all rich you know as far as we go
they've made millions and millions of
dollars but we're talking about billions
here the very public process ultimately
landed a-rod and j-lo's consortium as
the runner-up with cohen buying the team
for 2.4 billion dollars we are a little
bit depressed about it we don't like to
lose and um
you know we were really we started
getting really excited and thinking
about what could be and so when i was
when it just sort of came to a complete
halt it was sort of like the shock to
the system we were sort of depressed and
down
mark lori is a new york born businessman
who most recently had been a senior
executive at walmart
he'd gotten there by selling his company
jet.com to the mega retailer and stayed
on to run that division
and while a-rod's partnership with jlo
would come undone
he formed a close business and personal
connection with lori that's lasted house
rules man i told you no ties man
it's my favorite time
you grew up
uh in a sort of very similar way um and
from very very humble beginnings i love
mark i love him like a brother and he's
he's a great partner and a great friend
and
you know he sleeps in my house i sleep
at his house
and we both have this drive in this
mission that i want him to win in the
worst way and i think he does the same
for me i want to show you this clip
because
it spoke to me
a lot about
the depth of your relationship yeah i
think um
this is getting a little bit deeper now
but but i think it comes down to our
dads you know um that we both felt like
you know we had something to prove in
order to to sort of feel
love really and and when you did
something spectacular
you felt oh
maybe you know like uh and i think
he similarly had had felt that too where
if you wanted to to feel love you had to
do big things
what do you make of that
i never thought about it that way but i
know that when my father left
at 10
it left a huge hole in my heart and my
stomach
and
i knew that i had to do better
and i think before therapy
it was probably better for the wrong
things i think post and and current
i look at it as just my purpose
um but i also know that i'm enough now
and probably before that i thought it
wasn't
the deep connection with lori led to a
new 400 million venture fund called vcp
and notably allowed them to quickly
pivot to a successful deal in sports
ownership their pursuit of the minnesota
timberwolves and minnesota links he
called me and he said hey are you
serious about this he said i won't do it
unless you're serious about it and i
said i'm serious about it are you
serious about it
and again a minute conversation we're
both in and we probably got the deal
done in
six or seven days
nba ownership has radically transformed
in the past decade as tech executives
like steve ballmer and joe sai and wall
street investors like mark lazary josh
harris and tony ressler have snapped up
teams there's a supply demand imbalance
where anyone you know most people if
they could would own a professional
sports team and there's you know very
high barriers to entry
and you know very limited supply
in the case of the timberwolves glenn
taylor bought the team in 1994 for 88
million
the sale to rodriguez's group values the
franchise paired with the four-time wnba
champion links
at 1.5 billion dollars
and that's relatively affordable
a-rod's old team the yankees is worth
more than five billion dollars according
to several estimates and while ownership
is changing so too are the players
i think players today want more in every
sport
they're into fashion
they want to be good investors
they want to learn about adventure the
nba players today that i've been around
some of them are more prepped at 20 than
some of the guys that i played with at
where 50
and meeting with our athletes and
talking about business and
them reaching out to me it's it's great
it's humbling and it's really impressive
and if anything their ownership has
maybe gotten too close to the players
the team being fined 250 000 for
violating league rules with an
off-season workout in a rod's hometown
of miami
but buying a basketball team instead of
the mets might accomplish a goal he
thought was unreachable
actually making him cool to his
daughters
i recently went to a
sixers game
and my little one ella who's 13 she goes
dad i really like this basketball thing
like
one day maybe i get to you know run run
the business here one day really and i
was like oh my god that's like the
greatest thing i've ever heard and she
goes
you know it's like you know baseball's a
little slower but this stuff i can
really get into it i said well
baseball's great too it's just you know
it's more of a thinking man's game it's
like chess not checkers and she goes
yeah yeah whatever i don't like chess
either but she says
this basketball thing i have like real
passion is like the entertainment and i
have thoughts and i have ideas and i and
she thinks much more like like a
producer she likes dancing
and i mean to me that's just like boy
that's the great thing about sports and
music it brings people together and it
certainly did that for us that night
[Music]
you have built this this amazing
business you know there are people who
are watching this who's like this guy
you know it's like
that they'll always remember you for
your baseball career and a baseball
career that was controversial to say the
least you could be living on an island
somewhere you don't have to do this
i thought about tapping out a bunch of
times
i would wake up in the middle of the
night
and be in tears going like how
in the world do i get pocket aces and
figure out a way to screw this up
that was a very painful time for me
and i think the year suspension
allowed me
to not only
put lipstick on the house and paint it
and fix the windows
it allowed me to tear the entire house
down
and start building it one brick at a
time
and in that process i became even closer
to my daughters
and
when i think about those mistakes and
the lessons learned
i think about okay but you know what
that was baseball and
i had good moments and i had very tough
moments
but
clean slate when it comes to being a
father
to being a partner to being a
businessman to being a friend
so i
draw some incredible motivation
through
man something that
sucked something that i did to myself
i say to myself
in the darkest hour
boy if i ever get another opportunity
i'm not gonna screw that up again
and i'm trying my best not to do that
[Music]
you